[Music]  Nikki Bella and John Cena are trying to  work things out I know he's not gonna  get cold feet and run off like after  calling off their engagement last month  the couple seems to be on the mend a rep  for Nikki Bella tells et they're working  on their relationship and taking it  day-by-day their hidden talent is  patience because she puts up with me one  of the reasons behind John and Nikki's  initial split was due to her intense  desire to be a mom and his not wanting  kids at all and the day I really thought  I was okay not being a moment and it's  just been growing in me and I've been  just trying to push it to the side but  it clay it shouldn't be a situation of  you trying to push feelings to the side  rumours a reconciliation could happen  have been swirling since the 41 year old  blocker star appeared on The Today Show  earlier this month and John has not hid  that he wants Nikki back what sucks  there's no other way to say that that's  it's a love Nicole and  [Music]